many children have been returning to
school over the last few weeks and there
are still some open questions
about just how safe that is and what
happens if infections rise
over the winter well to talk about that
we're joined by the chair of global
public health at edinburgh
university professor debbie schrider
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning
schools are back should we expect to see
infection rates rise as a result
well that really comes down to the
testing and tracing system and how
quickly
cases within schools can be identified
through having surveillance in place
through having rapid testing in place
and how quickly the tracing teams can
ensure that
any other children in contact um with
this child have you know go into
isolation are tested as well
so it's really in our hands we've seen
variable experience in the world
from denmark which handled school return
exceptionally well
has kids back you know very little bump
in terms of their numbers
compared to israel where numbers just
skyrocketed because the testing and
tracing wasn't in place
i wonder as well if you could explain a
bit of a science to us because it does
feel as if there are lots of conflicting
reports out there
conflicting studies about the role that
children have in
spreading kovid 19 is there a difference
between
primary school-aged children secondary
age children what's your understanding
yeah so if we get back just to what we
know so far children
can have the virus regardless of their
age
they have the same viral load as adults
they can transmit the virus but for
an unconfirmed reason it seems primary
age children
transmit less than older children
meaning secondary age so we have seen
for example clusters and teenagers
occurring
and but primary school kids seem to be
less affected and some of the hypotheses
are about the social interactions of
primary school kids who they're around
they're around for example they're more
likely to be asymptomatic
which means coughing and sneezing is
less likely so not infecting others
as well as that primary school kids are
shorter and so they're less likely to
kind of be exposing adults or others
around
them so there is a difference but
science has not confirmed yet
what of those hypotheses it could be gas
medicine that could just be down to the
height of somebody on whether they
are passing it on or not um the
government is encouraging us to
get back to the office lots of people
are starting to go back into work now
which of course
poses child care issues for lots of
working parents
is it safe for grandparents to start
picking up child care responsibilities
now
well i think the the key answer to that
depends on what's happening locally
because is it safe enough is really the
bar you're trying to pass
if you're on a scottish island where
there's no new cases for weeks or other
parts of southwest of the
um of england then probably you're
pretty okay picking up picking up your
children because the likelihood of your
child
having an infection at school is so low
um if you're in a place which is in a
local
lockdown or has local restrictions in
place or numbers are increasing
um then i would say to be more cautious
just for that time
until hopefully those numbers come down
and this is why the government really
needs to commit to maximum suppression
of this virus
because children don't exist in a bubble
um all of us interact every day with
vulnerable individuals with elderly
individuals
they're a part of our society and we
need to ensure that we suppress the
virus so all of us can live
together um through this crisis we'll be
talking to dominic raab
uh after you uh and you're talking about
the government strategy
what do you make of where we are
currently uh when it comes to track and
trace when it comes to what the
government's overall strategy is
when it comes to cover 19. well i think
on the
positive side what we're seeing across
europe and this is true whether it's
germany whether it's now in britain
denmark
also for example sweden is they're
moving towards a model of maximum
suppression that if you want to get
normality back if you want the economy
to recover you need to control the virus
very tightly
and that's now i guess come together
that actually control the virus
you get your better economic recovery
and there i think the uk is committing
the key element here is getting the
testing faster and this is why
i'm a little bit worried about the back
to office push alongside the back to
school push
so what we've seen in scotland over the
past few weeks is the testing system has
just been
you know really having to race to catch
up with the demand of all the children
coming home with coughs and colds and
fevers
if you add on top of that all the adults
going back into offices and having those
as well your testing system is really
under strain
so you have to get ready get your
testing system going so people get the
results fast enough and the tracing
teams can get going
that's the main way to suppress this
virus and not have to put in place
restrictions
when the testing and tracing starts to
break down that's when you need your
local restrictions
where you have restrictions on let's say
going to other people's homes or on pubs
in hospitality or on riskier settings
so i think that's where we are now i
think we're unlikely to have another
national like lockdown we've learned a
lot about this virus
but it's up to the testing and tracing
and all of each of us and our behaviors
to make sure that
you know we make sure the virus stays
suppressed and we can keep things
running as much as fully as normally as
possible
um another big question that some are
talking about is whether or not they
should be testing at airports it's
something that
labour is calling for and we're of
course seeing increased infection rates
on the continent places like france and
spain do you think the government should
be looking at testing in airports
yes definitely i think the uk government
as a whole have been behind the curve in
terms of border control
one of the latest to put in border
restrictions and when they have been put
in place
um you know not really being monitored
in terms of compliance with them and
also being quite a harsh measure for the
aviation industry and and creating
uncertainty
so i think yes we definitely need a
better approach the problem with just
testing at an airport is that of the
incubation period of the virus meaning
people could test negative and then
you know go into pubs and bars and
engage fully in their lives and then
pass on the virus because they've just
been incubating it
you know in the pre um and symptomatic
phase
and so i think what we need to be having
is probably testing at airports plus
testing maybe
five to eight days later and then at
that point if you have two negative
tests and you can get on with your life
um but i think testing is really the key
to a lot of these issues of escaping
lockdown escape and quarantine
all those restrictions if you want to
lift them you got to get your testing in
place
we were talking a bit earlier about um
different risk levels i guess so if
you're a grandparent you might be
thinking that you can have different
interactions based on the infection
rates in your local area
and i just wondered there's so many
figures around
what numbers should it be that we're all
looking at you know should we be looking
at
case numbers hospital admissions the r8
what exactly should we trust
well i just look at three for different
countries when i try to compare them i
look at three pieces of data the first
is cases per 100 000
but these again are confirmed cases so
if countries are not testing enough they
might have
lower numbers so you also need to look
at your testing positivity that's the
number of people testing positive over
the total number
of people tested and that'll give you an
indication isn't enough testing
occurring
for example now it's parts the united
states you're having positivity between
30 to 40 percent which is incredibly
high
or in the uk luckily it seems to be
generally under two to three percent
um and the third is actually how many
cases are tied to clusters so if i see a
spike but most of them are coming from a
factory outbreak that seems like it
could be circled
you could do extensive testing it hasn't
spread you know widely then i'm less
worried
if you're seeing numbers go up and
they're all over the country and you're
unable to connect them
that tells you you've got substantial
community spread and that's more
worrying
so i guess it's those three things it's
your cases it's your positivity and it's
how many are tied to clusters
okay thank you so much for uh talking
through uh the figure it's always good
to have you on the show thank you
thank you for having me